i've tried to prepare myself
um not having reps with a lot of these
guys
that my footwork
marries drews
so everything times up the same with
those guys and
you know i think that so far it's it's
made first minute transition
obviously my my role has changed
this week
but the preparation
and the hard work
throughout the week has not so
carrying on that same mentality that
i've always had this year
always being able or being ready to
answer the phone when it rings and
it's drinking so
ready to answer
big challenge for both of these
quarterbacks and taysom hill has had
three weeks of experience now to get
himself more comfortable and more
importantly to get the receivers more
comfortable you have to work on the
timing you don't get reps with the
starting receivers when you're the
backup taysom hill told me after the win
over the falcons on sunday that that's
been one of the reasons why his passing
has improved more time working with the
receivers working after practice with
the receivers taking the mental reps
necessary to get himself as he said to
perform like drew brees does so the
receivers are comfortable with the
offense and that gives him a huge
advantage because for hill it's game
number four for hertz it's game number
one on the fly one week of prep
peter and for hertz look this is
something that jason kelsey said earlier
this week it's been a total failure for
the eagles offense i really don't think
swapping out carson wentz for jalen
hurts is going to change all that much
for an offense that is bad across the
board
i don't either but i think there are
sometimes where your franchise
quarterback and i still believe he will
be that
in 2021 although we can discuss the
alternatives i think the best thing for
your franchise quarterback
is to stop taking the physical and media
and mental beating that carson wentz has
taken over the last three months
sometimes you just have to say
i don't know what the alternative is we
don't know about jalen hurts but you
know what
this guy needs to sit down and it's time
for him to sit down i think doug
peterson made
not just the right sporting call he made
the humane call because it just felt so
much you know i had great cosell on my
podcast this week everybody knows how
smart cosell is watching tate
well you know i said to him it looks
like carson wentz in my opinion is
seeing ghosts
and
so everybody says well what does that
mean well when you take the snap back
from center and immediately you're
looking to bail out you're not staying
in the pocket and that's because
you know he's got so many issues
in pass pro
and that has been his issue the entire
year so it's really hard to blame it all
on carson wentz but you can see now
that
his his quickness to get out of the
pocket is preventing
pass routes from developing
so you never can really tell
whether anybody was going to be open or
not they don't have time to see by that
time he's bailed out
and i and i just think
you know it has built on itself so now
you bring a quarterback in whose game in
part is his feet
and carson wentz his game in part was
his feet in 2017
but now instead of using his feet to
make plays he's just using his feet as
an escape mechanism
let's see if jalen hurts can do any
better and one other thing i'll say
about hertz
mike
he has played at the highest level
of college football in two specific
programs where all eyes are on him
and and i think that's gonna hold him in
good stead andy reid always used to
laugh about if i would ever say what
about all the media crap in philly you
know w-i-p and and all this stuff he
goes who cares and and i think to some
degree jalen hurts is probably going to
feel the same way
well
and so my question becomes
especially in light of the market where
the fans are very passionate where the
super bowl from three years ago bought
no one a pass if anything it increased
the zeal with which the fan base wants
to pursue number two and number three
and beyond
how do you press the reset button for
carson wentz if jalen hurts plays well
it's over for carson wentz if he doesn't
play well if he fails
then maybe there's a way
to get people to understand that it
wasn't carson
and that perhaps
you
go back to zero and zero and next year
you give them another opportunity you
know they don't have a lot of
flexibility because of the contract that
has 25 million fully guaranteed already
for 2021 another 15 million for 2022
becomes fully guaranteed the middle of
march of 2021
they are stuck with carson once
financially i just don't know after you
bench him peter how you get to a point
where you can hit that reset button and
the fans will buy in and he will have an
opportunity
to rebuild himself without crumbling
under the weight of the same pressures
that have crumbled him now
joe banner said something interesting
this week mike i thought about the
contract that basically no contract is
untradeable
now this contract obviously would be
really uncomfortable
for the trading team of course and the
acquiring team but if you change some of
that money
into uh into a signing bonus
and have it basically massaged over the
life of the deal it's not it's still
very bad but it's not heinous you know
and it's not 59 million dollars but
i'll just say one thing about
the way this thing right now i believe
is sculpted
some team out there is going to have to
want
carson wentz
and the only team i see that could
potentially
want carson wins is the indianapolis
colts
now
you might say well geez you know they're
doing they're doing fine they'll figure
out the quarterback maybe it won't be
jacoby brissette probably won't be
phillip rivers but they'll figure it out
look chris ballard the general manager
of the colts and frank wright the head
coach want a long-term quarterback they
don't want scotch tape fixes
and so
my my whole thought about this is i'm
not saying the cults are going to be
interested but i believe knowing chris
ballard knowing frank wright especially
ballard that he will study this
situation
fervently
and that he will look at this situation
and he'll say does it make any sense for
us to even consider it but finally mike
the one thing i think that's going to be
trouble
in this whole thing is
the eagles have to say
blindly
blandly that carson wentz is our guy
they cannot make it seem like they are
going to talk to anybody
there's got to be an omerta
over any sort of discussion that you
would have with the indianapolis colts
or with any team that no one
involved in any of those discussions
would even admit it to their wives you
know that it's got to be totally silent
that's the only way i think it could
work because if carson once finds out if
anybody in philadelphia finds out that
they've been trying to deal him then
bang the thing could all blow up
the one thing you can't do is cut carson
once because you've got the 25 million
obligation in 2021 now there's offset
language but no one's going to pay him
25 million not only are you going to
take the huge cap hit for the
acceleration of the signing bonus that
he was paid and the other guarantees he
was given you carry that salary the
trade isn't as impossible as it was for
a brock osweiler out of houston where
the texans had to actually give the
browns a second round pick to take on
the 16 million dollar fully guaranteed
salary that osweiler was due to make in
2017
but
that this is the challenge from the
eagles perspective they're going to be
carrying a 34 million dollar cap number
next year
for wentz whether he's on the team or
not but if he's not on the team you do
avoid that 40 million in new cash
obligations that would attach can you
get a team like the colts to say we'll
take wentz at 25 million in a cash
obligation for this year with or without
a signing bonus that spreads out the cap
hit the cap it's not the issue they
signed phillip rivers this year to a one
year 25 million dollar contract back in
march if you had said to any colts fan
you can have philip rivers for one year
25 million you can have carson wentz for
one year 25 million they all would have
said we'll take wentz now there may be a
different attitude this year but there's
one colts fan who matters and that's
frank reich frank reich was the
offensive coordinator when wentz was an
mvp finalist before he suffered the torn
acl three years ago today
if reich doesn't want him that's the
ultimate litmus test sims and i were
talking about this earlier in the week
if mike doesn't want him then no one
should want him peter
yeah i agree um but i think frank wright
will want him that's just my gut feeling
and if frank wright does want him
then it's a matter of what would the
eagles take uh would they need to have
what they would consider fair
compensation or would they just want to
say
look we want to do a solid for carson
wentz it just didn't work out and mike
you know you said it there's a lot of
people who would say
it really doesn't matter what jalen
hurts does in the next three weeks
because this is going to all be about
carson once well i would disagree with
that a lot
i think if jalen hurts plays well
in the last three four weeks of the
season however much he plays if he plays
well
and they look at him
as being a good quarterback behind a
scotch tape leaky offensive line geez
what's he going to do when he gets to be
gets to be behind a better performing
line and one other thing
what is the comp that a lot of people
made when jalen hurts was drafted the
comp was dak prescott
and i'm not saying in any way shape or
form that jalen hurts is ever going to
be dak prescott but
they're guys who play well in the pocket
who also can move out of the pocket
either to gain yards or to throw the
ball on the move
and so to me i think if you use that
maybe as your model it's a little bit
too much but if you use that just to
keep in mind this is the style of
quarterback that jalen hurts is gonna be
and if he can be that today
and in the future and prove that he can
be that style of quarterback i think
that's going to appeal to the eagles
quarterback issues in philadelphia that
date back to 2016 quarterback issues in
chicago dating to 2017 have created a
situation where gm head coach maybe both
are on the hot seat
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports